ready okay
let's do this
[Music]
people always say don't assume the worst
you're excited yeah this is a boy or
girl
we don't know
sometimes the worst is exactly what you
should assume
so my wife is in the hospital she's
about to give birth drive this is a
family emergency I'm your family
emergency now
whatever it is you want it's yours
this is the wife David where are you
I mean are you happy you and your wife
have a happy marriage take away from my
family
that's rude you interrupting me don't
you know what I don't need tonight
stress
watch the speed limit where we going
you're not listening to me I will shoot
you
and this cop
I told you not to speed
we should play a little game I want you
to tell me the truth if you don't I am
going to kill Mr Happy trucker and this
waitress ready
you got me confused with someone else
that's not who you think I am told you
who I think you are so how did you know
you're not who I think you are
sit back down
it's getting good
I'm not gonna die tonight
I dressed up for this I I wanted to be a
hundred percent sex tonight and you cut
that in half I'm now 50 sex
I think the more violent to death the
higher the heaven you go
better rain in hell wouldn't you agree
pick up the phone James what what are
you ghosting me
what are you Dr Ross my psychiatrist